Mad Max fury road is directed by George
Miller and stars Tom Hardy Charlize
Theron and Nicholas Hoult and this movie
is the continuation of the Mad Max
series now if you've never the Mad Max
series first off where have you been and
why do you watch movies do you have any
idea how much these three films have
influenced movies today I'm a fan of the
Mad Max movies a third one wasn't that
great
road warrior is one of the best action
movies ever from the 80s and Mad Max was
a great revenge movie they're all
directed by George Miller and the last
one came out thirty years ago and we're
finally getting a new look into this
world from the same person who created
it Oh in this movie max played by Tom
Hardy has been captured by this strange
group of people who are led by this
person they almost view as a religious
figure he's got this crazy mask my buddy
Craig candy Co of phat movie guy calm
described him as Skeletor and Darth
Vader's love child Charlize Theron 's
character is trying to get a group of
people to safety that she cares for very
deeply while also finding her homeland
and Mad Max is sort of the guy caught in
the middle of all this and he has to
figure out which side he's on now
regards to action movies there are some
landmarks what you might call milestones
1981 Raiders of the Lost Ark 1988 die
hard 1991 Terminator 2 Judgment Day 1999
The Matrix 2008 The Dark Knight 2015 Mad
Max fury road this movie was incredible
it was so good I cannot believe how
excited I am to Tellez movie just it's
everything I want to action movie to be
guys 2015 is done
Mad Max for broke the year the years
broken Mad Max for years you've finished
it it's done too much just don't even go
to see another movie this year you're
done I'm a huge fan of action filmmaking
I take it very seriously if you guys
didn't see the video I did called the
problem with action movies today it was
shared by dozens of some of the biggest
entertainment websites on the internet
I'm not just patting myself on the back
what I'm saying is everyone sort of has
this worry about action movies now
everyone pretty much feels the same way
they're not that good anymore what has
happened George Miller has returned to
make everything right again
everything about the way the action is
directed in this movie the intensity the
rawness the realistic sense to it all
the sense of vulnerability of our hero
who is constantly in peril almost every
second and every scene this movie
someone is beaten on this guy it's
fantastic I couldn't believe how much
fun I had with this movie it by far is
the best movie I've seen so far this
year it might be the best action movie
I've seen so far this decade I'm serious
it might be guys it might actually be
the best action movie had a decade Wow I
lost my mind I lost it it's gone that
being said when this movie ended the
woman behind me went oh thank God I
turned around I was like you didn't like
it and she said no I really hated it and
I was like have you ever seen a Mad Max
movie before she went no this is my
first one and I was like yeah it's uh
hmm I just kind of turned around I was
it's like well maybe you shouldn't have
come to this movie if you've never seen
a Mad Max movie and it's the fourth Mad
Max movie why would you come to this
movie going into this movie you need to
recognize it's insane this movie's nuts
it's crazy there's a guy playing
electric guitar on top of a truck
shooting flames out of the neck of the
guitar does that sound cool to you if it
does go see this movie cuz you're gonna
love it it honestly it is a non-stop
action thrill ride and it also has a
surprising amount of feeling to it
especially with Charlize Theron scare
achter because once you learn some of
the things that's going on her backstory
and the things that she needs and once
max sees this and they start to take
note of some of these problems
the movie actually gets really
emotionally powerful at times and Tom
Hardy is excellent as Max he is so good
I'm a big fan of Gibson's portrayal of
Mad Max he had big shoes to fill and he
did an excellent excellent job doing so
I was very satisfied with his hand and
combat scenes the helming of those
scenes there's no shaky cam
to be found beautiful wide shots of
chaos and destruction that will just
leave you drooling it's so well helmed I
just loved it I'll say this this is the
best 80s action movie that never came
out in the 80s ever I'm not the kind of
person that sits here and exaggerate you
know and fanboys I'll admit there have
been times a couple years ago where I
have fan Boyd over films that weren't as
good as I said they were and that's
because I just was younger and I've
learned more since then I'm older now
and I'm becoming a jaded old man I guess
but the honest truth is guys I'm not
exaggerating Mad Max fury road is one of
the best action films I've ever seen
it's probably the best action film I've
seen so far this decade I'd have to
think about that but I'm pretty sure it
is and it's by far the best movie I've
seen so far this year guys if you don't
see this movie I will be disappointed in
you do not make this 2015 edge of
tomorrow
go see Mad Max fury road as soon as you
can Mad Max fury road gets an A+ do you
realize I gave only two of those grades
out last year to just two a-pluses guys
this is the action movie you've been
waiting for if you've seen Mad Max fury
road let me know what you thought of it
below be wary of spoilers for those who
haven't seen it please and thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck Manoj